[Musica]
ascoltiamo just works and vibration
il team trascina da sangue chiesto prone
training course and free call service
course consiglio sono in crisi
praticamente quello che è successo in
questo esperimento è che il primo
oggetto entrato in risonanza acustica
con l'altro senza esserne a contatto
io penso che questa questo tipo di
azione di attività possa anche essere
dentro di noi dentro ogni essere umano
tanto che lo vorrei chiamare piccola
risonanza empatica in quanto tanto
dipende appunto dalle empatia
ma per farvelo capire un po meglio mi
piacerebbe raccontarvi una storia nella
storia che parte dal 2015 quando ero
appena rientrato da un viaggio in
america da boston e finalmente era
arrivato a godermi la mia estate nel
piccolo paesino nakata in provincia di
ragusa dove abitano i miei genitori e la
mia famiglia quella di mia moglie cioè
dove trascorrono l'estate in piena
tranquillità
quindi eravamo lì seduti nella veranda
quando a un certo punto vuoi il fuso
orario probabilmente guardo l'orologio
della piazza e proprio lì accanto e dico
cavolo fuso orario mi sta fregando sono
le due di notte
e ancora siamo qui a chiacchierare sennò
giovanni guarda non sono le due di notte
e sono le undici e come l'orologio fa le
due l'orologio lotto come l'orologio è
rotto scusa si è rotto da un bel po di
tempo
cavolo l'orologio della piazza che è un
qualcosa che dovrebbe effettivamente a
dare il movimento la dinamica a questa
piazza è rotto
dico no non può essere dobbiamo fare
qualcosa per aggiustarlo molto
probabilmente quell'energia quella
vibrazione era derivata dal fatto che io
ritornavo dalle menti a boston dove
c'era stato l'incontro con tutti i fab
lab mondiali ogni anno viene fatto un
incontro in tutto il mondo quell'anno
era proprio nel punto dove nacquero i
fab lab dove nel green field si era
inventato questo fabbricazione del
laboratorio di fabbricazione digitale
che guarda caso usa le tecnologie che
che rappresentiamo in roland e che
racchiude una quantità enorme di persone
che hanno voglia di fare cose
e credetemi in quelle giornate sono
successe delle cose incredibili
una tra le più belle e successo un
sabato mattina quando una ragazza dice
ma perché non costruiamo un sottomarino
e lo pensa il sottomarino telecomandato
non ho un sottomarino per attraversare
il fiume charlie da una parte all'altra
e lì
la cosa interessante è che queste
persone non è che dicono ma sei matta ma
che ti viene in mente no iniziano a
progettare a disegnare a usare laser
frese arduino iniziano a montare a
creare programmi alla fine
domenica mattina il sottomarino fatto
quei secchioni della spazzatura tutto
quello che volete
era lì pronto ad attraversare il fiume
charlie a boston
incredibile hulk ecco questa energia
capite sono arrivato e superando tutte
quelle problematiche che in effetti
abbiamo avuto uno autorizzazioni è ma
non sei autorizzato a salire sulla torre
cavolo ma dammi la chiave non te la
posso dare e cercare gli stratagemmi per
arrivare a capire qual era il problema
per poterlo risolvere
alla fine con due amici che avevano
risposto al mio appello su facebook
finalmente riusciamo a salire e ci
ritroviamo questa meraviglia di orologio
del inizio secolo del 1920
elettromeccanico con due quadranti
giganti lo puliamo cerchiamo di capire
qual era il problema perché alcuni
dicevano si è rotto un pezzo
nessuno sapeva il perché e mario un
amico che era salito su guarda il
pendolo e mette il dito nel pendolo e
l'orologio prende vita praticamente a
nessuno si era preso la briga di salire
nella torre per mettere un dito per
muovere un pendolo la cosa ti fa star
male
inizia a pensare ma come si fa ok
ritorniamo l'orologio funziona ritorno a
san benedetto del tronto dove vivo e
ricevo una telefonata ma erano passati
due mesi giovanni e giovanni dimmi
guarda un fulmine ha colpito l'orologio
si è rotto non funziona e va beh io sono
qua scusa mille chilometri di distanza
fate voi
si no l'aia aggiustato tu cioè mi è
sembrato più la storia di ritorno al
futuro
incredibile c'è proprio come il ritorno
al futuro capite cioè l'orologio fulmine
la cosa in qualche maniera penso che
questa è una pulce perché ho messo una
pulce perché mi è venuta in mente la
pulce la pulce praticamente salta 150
volte quella che è la grandezza del suo
corpo e il che è molto interessante come
potenza di bilancio di salto però se voi
prendete una boccia tipo quella dei
pesci non la mettete sopra la pulce la
pulce farà il primo salto sbatte la
testa sul vetro e dice cavolo mi sono
fatta male faccio un saltino un po più
piccolo e inizia a saltare sempre un po
meno sempre un po meno sempre un po meno
fin quanto non si fa male se tu levi la
boccia la pur se continuerà a saltare
quel poco per non farsi male ma lui non
sa che non c'è la boccia e noi acate
taranto tante città ci hanno questa
bozza apparente sopra che non fa saltare
al di là di quel fosso nella boccia
mentale capite e quindi quest'anno sono
partito quando sono arrivata ad agosto
logicamente bekhti feature save the
clock tower e quindi vado mi creo st
maglietta sempre con le tecnologie c'è
la fortuna di potermi creare quello che
voglio gilet papillon scarpe eccetera
la personalizzazione è una figata perché
crea in qualche maniera
un richiamo che capite che unicità a me
è servita perché questo messaggio l'ho
studiato e ho studiato pure una sorta di
comunicazione da fare nei riguardi del
paese è molto pesante molto forte anche
un pochettino violento
capite cioè ho iniziato a comunicare in
questa maniera e iniziano ad arrivare le
prime adesioni dai sì c'è praticamente
le persone con questa provocazione la
fanno propria figo ora arrivano anche
altri tipi di persone che dicono ah no
lo deve fare il comune
dobbiamo fare una autorizzazione o
capite quindi nella conversazione tra i
100 partecipanti 90 su quelli che
osservano 9 iniziano a rompere pure le
scatole ma uno è quello che contribuisce
a me serviva quell 1 ma serviva a farmi
tanti di uni e quindi iniziò a scherzare
su sta storia dicendo per esempio come
faremo a mettere il filo elettrico dalla
torre a alla torre b e lì tutte a dire
le col drone usa lager [ __ ] no usa il
cioè credetemi c'è un boss che è
straordinario con una quantità enorme di
soluzioni per fare questo passaggio di
corrente elettrica che ho fatto in
diretta live su facebook facendo vedere
quello che stavamo facendo realmente
sopra la torre altra cosa interessante è
che quella t shirt è piaciuta a tanti
quindi tanti mi dicevano bella sa di
share
ma la possa avere cavolo poi avevamo
pure dei costi da sostenere che
all'inizio con gli amici quei tre amici
hanno deciso di sostenerli in proprio
però l'idea di fare una maglietta di
metterla in vendita ci ha consentito di
ottenere anche un beneficio economico
che non avevamo capito c'è nessuno ci
avrebbe dato i soldi tanto bene il
comune che era un po in dissesto aveva
dei problemi anzi male ha detto che
poteva fare delle cose però in effetti
ho voluto di staccare la politica da
questa azione perché la nazione fatta da
piccoli persone anzi vi dirò di più che
tanti si sono prodigati ci hanno dato
degli switch che non si trovavano mango
su amazon è stato bellissimi ci ha fatto
gli avvolgimenti perché aveva la cultura
di fare l'avvolgimento e logicamente
tenevo in contatto tutti quanti
e portandoli sopra la torre e facendo
vedere quello che stavamo facendo giorno
dopo giorno
questa storia ha avuto anche un
passaggio mediatico il quotidiano la
sicilia ci ha dedicato una doppia pagina
tenete conto che c'è stata pure una
storia di chi non voleva le campane di
notte chi le voleva l'abbiamo spento
riacceso abbiamo creato proprio uno
scompiglio per far muovere far risuonare
il paese
ma la cosa più interessante che su
questa storia
abbiamo costruito una community una
community di persone perché ognuno di
loro io tuttora ogni ogni tanto ricevo
le foto della t shirt in australia
spettacolare bellissimo e meraviglioso
stessa cosa
l'ho fatta 16 anni fa quando ho creato
la community dell'artigiano tecnologico
erano artigiane che approcciavano al
digitale capite l'artigiano col digitale
ha paura quindi gli o connessi tra di
loro e tra di loro si dà uno piccoli
consigli che consentivano appunto di
andare avanti nel lavoro essere molto
più vicini le community ora quello che
ho compreso che questa risonanza
empatica
in effetti nasce da un emettitore molto
probabilmente quella visita al m team ad
atene un energia veramente forte che la
data pure agli amici del poli factory
quando hanno fatto il fab lab al
politecnico l'ha dato agli amici indiani
quando hanno costruito il loro
laboratorio la data a me in quel momento
in cui ho deciso di aggiustare
l'orologio la prima volta e come tale
noi che abbiamo fatto sta operazione è
quest'anno abbiamo dato l'energia a
tutto il resto dei ragazzi che hanno
partecipato e loro oggi credetemi stanno
facendo cose hanno ripulito le porte
della chiesa
coi soldi che ci sono rimasti dalle
magliette stanno andando avanti a fare
delle azioni che prima non avrebbero
fatto e quindi
questo palco parlando a voi a me
piacerebbe che ognuno di voi
ritornando a taranto nel suo paesino
ovunque iniziasse a pensare ad una
piccola azione a fare un qualcosa di
diverso di praticare è condividere dei
piccoli atti di gentilezza che generano
rilevanti risonanze positive grazie
[Applauso]